do you have any tips for applying for
jobs under an AI platform it's been a
while since I've been in the job market
one you've got to use keywords so if you
read a job description let's say it's
about a three or four paragraph job
description you've got to be paying
attention to keywords in the description
Tony and then you make sure that those
are in your interview
so for instance if it says you need a
lot of experience with Excel just using
a simple example then make sure one of
your skills on your resume is Excel so
that that AI System picks up on that
second make sure that you edit every
resume to be custom for the job a lot of
people are doing a cut and paste and
putting out multiple resumes multiple
jobs that'll get you flagged and then
third don't apply for too many roles at
one company